im april hat der kinderkanal von ard und
zdf kika eine neue serie gestartet sie
heißt völlig meschugge google hebräisch
für verrückt die geschichte von drei
freunden die sich in ihrem schulalltag
mit mobbing und antisemitismus
auseinander setzen müssen ein
ambitioniert ist ein gutes projekt
die frage ist allerdings ob sich der
kicker nicht auch mit
israelfeindlichkeit in den eigenen
reihen auseinandersetzen muss
schreie vermummte personen teilweise
bewaffnet mit steinen anti israel demo
in palästina mittendrin dieser mann
teilnehmer des israel-feindlichen
jugendfestivals in vater im
westjordanland und moderator beim
öffentlich-rechtlichen fernsehsender
kieker
hallo der tag ist rom es ist baumhaus
zeit matondo castello eines der
gesichter der serie das baumhaus auf dem
kindersender soll der kleinen kindern
wissen und werte vermitteln in palästina
nimmt er an israel feindlichen
demonstrationen teil und verbringt zeit
mit kerim schamberger dieser ist ein
selbst ernannter kommunist und
unterstützer der anti israelischen
boykottbewegung bds also die bewegung
die den staat israel wirtschaftlich
politisch und kulturell isolieren will
und sein existenzrecht infrage stellt
dass israel feindliche jugend festival
wird auf der website kommunisten de
vorgestellt und mit matondo castros
teilnahme beworben zwei absätze weiter
schreiben sie über die sogenannte
apartheids aufschrei empörung bei der
öffentlich rechtlichen sendeanstalt es
wäre überraschend denn es scheint das
gebührenfinanzierte fernsehen ist auf
dem antisemitismus auge blind
nene al hassan sun ti semitismus vorfall
sorgte deutschlandweit für schlagzeilen
die 28 jährige sollte die wissenschaft
sendung quarks auf dem wdr moderieren
doch kurz vor beginn ihrer
öffentlich-rechtlichen karriere enthüllt
bild el hassan nimmt im jahr 2014 am
berliner alkmaar steil eine
antisemitische hetze veranstaltung auf
der kippa tragen die juden angegriffen
und die vernichtung israels gefordert
wurde damit nicht genug bei social media
unterstützte sie beiträge über die
ermordung eines juden daraufhin nahm der
wdr abstand von der geplanten
zusammenarbeit
unvergessen auch die anti israel demo in
berlin mai vergangenen jahres mehr als
3000 männer und frauen strömen auf die
straßen skandieren antisemitische
parolen wie scheiß jude und tel aviv
bombardiert
und die tagesthemen
viele teilnehmende wollten deutlich
machen dass sie gewalt in nahost
verurteilen ganz offensichtlich israel
feindliche personen durften zur besten
sendezeit zu wort kommen
antisemitismus israel feindlichkeit und
ignoranz beim öffentlich rechtlichen
fernsehen empörung gibt es dafür auch
aus der politik das ist inakzeptabel und
frage mich manchmal was schief gestrickt
ist wenn man sich die lage anschauen
israel einziges land mit menschenrechten
demokratie und gleichberechtigung im
gesamten nahen osten auch im vergleich
zu palästina und trotzdem kommt das
selbsternannte bollwerk für demokratie
und gegen extremismus wie der öffentlich
rechtliche rundfunk sich bezeichnet da
sein ansprüchen nicht im ansatz
hinterher auf bild anfrage teilt kicker
mit den fall castro prüfen zu wollen der
sender kenne den 28 jährigen als person
die sich deutlich gegen hass und gewalt
positioniert und jetzt wieder live zu
unserem bild feuer reporter zu benjamin
trump dort in den berliner grunewald
also wir hören ein bisschen gute
nachricht aus der nach dass man da ja
das feuer hat eindämmen können und
gleichzeitig weiß man doch bisher weiter
nicht was ich tatsächlich da auf diesem
spreng geländer auf diesem sprengplatz
tatsächlich abgespielt hat was da alles
in die luft gegangen ist beispielsweise
das wollen wir jetzt rauskriegen klar
ist 42 hektar wald grunewald sind seit
gestern betroffen der sicherheitsradius
wurde gestern auf 1000 meter
eingerichtet der konnte jetzt nach
rücksprache mit dem sprengmeister
gelockert werden so dass die
einsatzkräfte jetzt in rücksprache mit
dem springen meist ein einzelfall auf
bis zu 500 meter an den brandherd heran
kommen können neben mir steht jetzt
thomas kirstein der pressesprecher der
berliner feuerwehr die löscharbeiten
laufen nach wie vor es besteht aber
unverändert die gefahr weiterer
explosionen wie gefährlich ist die lage
momentan da wir haben ja zwei große
schwerpunkte einmal ist es der
sprengplatz von dem weitere explosion
drohen wir können dort immer noch nicht
tätig werden also wir wollen heute dort
jetzt erstmal erkundung einführen dafür
brauchen wir gepanzerte fahrzeuge dass
der sprengmeister polizei berlin dort
sich ein lagebild verschaffen kann
dieses lagebild ist wichtig zur
einordnung des sperrkreises der
sperrkreis für die bevölkerung sind
weiterhin 1000 meter wir begeben uns als
einsatzkräfte die gefahr bis auf 500
meter sie haben es angesprochen haben
damit wir diesen waldbrand weiterhin
bekämpfen und auch klein halten dass
sich der wald hier nicht weiter der
waidmann sich nicht weiter ausbreitet
wie es sind jetzt die weitere strategie
der einsatzkräfte da wir wären jetzt mit
massiven löschmaßnahmen im waldgebiet
weiterhin tätig sein also in den
sperrkreis auch das machen wir von den
wegen dort wo wir an kleinere
brandnester die es immer noch gibt nicht
rankommen dort wären entweder schneisen
durch panzer der bundeswehr geschlagen
oder durch einen gepanzerten lösch
panzer oder wir werden auch mit robotern
die löschen können dort vorgehen wir
haben gestern gelernt dass schwere
bomben in speziellen behältern
aufbewahrt werden die auch gekühlt
werden welche gefahr besteht nach wie
vor vor diesem schweren bomben nur die
diese frage kann nur der sprengmeister
beantworten ja polizei berlin die jetzt
dringend dann auch dort bilder machen
möchten oder sich halt auch vor ort an
einblick verschaffen das geschieht
gemeinsam mit der bundeswehr davon hängt
eigentlich heute alles ab der bundeswehr
roboter theodor kamen gestern zum
einsatz der wurde ins brandgebiet
geschickt um bilder zu machen musste
dann aber abdrehen aufgrund von weiteren
explosionen weiteren detonationen jetzt
heute plan b was ist da angesagt er
musste sich gestern bei der erkundung er
war bereits auf dem sprengplatz im
einsatz zurückziehen oder die ganze
technik und natürlich auch die
einsatzkräfte diabolisch tages an enorm
nah dran waren bei dieser situation der
polizei berlin wurden wieder
zurückgezogen und man hat jetzt
praktisch die nacht abgewartet um zu
gucken wie es die entwicklung auf dem
sprengplatz ist jetzt wichtig dort vom
sprengplatz neue erkenntnisse zu kriegen
damit wir dann hoffentlich irgendwann im
laufe des tages den sperrkreis
eingrenzen können und die abos und der
bahnverkehr wieder freigegeben kann sie
haben die einsatzkräfte angesprochen wie
wird sich um die aktuell gekümmert wie
geht es denen ja wir haben frische
einsatzkräfte hier die einsatzkräfte
nach tätig waren sind alle ausgelöste
sind am feierabend so soll es sein wir
haben jetzt frische einsatzkräfte auch
der freiwilligen feuerwehr mit einer
brandschutz bereitschaft hier ist jetzt
ordentlich ressourcen technik und
einsatzkräfte da wir sind gut
aufgestellt die problematik jetzt
aktuell wetterbedingt es ist windig
geworden das könnte die flammen jetzt
nochmal erneut anfachen welche gefahr
besteht da und inwiefern wenn wir in
richtung himmel gucken hier kommt jetzt
einer dieser gepanzerten lösch roboter
an dieses alleinstellungsmerkmal können
sie uns doch mal ganz kurz erläutern wir
sind sehr froh wir haben jetzt
unterstützung aus niedersachsen die sind
gut aufgestellt die haben
spezielle technik und die komplizierten
abstimmung mit uns wir beschreiben
praktisch den kollegen aus niedersachsen
welche probleme die wir haben und die
unterstützen uns mit ihrer technik und
das ganz besondere an diesem lösch
roboter ist er kann tatsächlich nicht
nur bilder machen wie theodor gestern
sondern er kann tatsächlich auch wasser
abgeben er kann wasser abgeben das ist
der große unterschied und deswegen haben
wir diese spezielle technik herangeführt
gefahrenabwehr macht nicht an
ländergrenzen halt wir sind da gut
vernetzt bundesweit und sind
vorsichtiger sagt jetzt hier sind und
jetzt noch einmal ganz kurz wir haben
den wind angesprochen aber auch den
blick zum himmel es ist regen angesagt
wie sehr hofft man da auch als feuerwehr
auf ein bisschen unterstützung in diesen
sekunden von oben ja ich hatte vorhin
mit einem förster sprung bei dieser
forster sagte es müsste schon richtig
dahl und starkregen ihm dass es uns hier
massiv nach vorne bringt im moment
erwarten wir sowieso auf den regen dann
muss man auch erst mal gucken wie viel
und ob das überhaupt auswirkungen hat
darauf verlassen wir uns nicht aus
wetter an dieser stelle wir werden hier
heute vormittag sehr sehr viel wasser in
den wald bringen mit mehreren
tanklöschfahrzeugen mit wasserwerfern
der polizei da sind wir gut vorbereitet
mehr gestern löschboot einer havel in
stellung gebracht es gibt
schlauchleitung zur krummen lanke also
wasser ist hier nicht das problem wieder
ein illegales autorennen wieder ein
schwerer unfall dadurch wieder mitten in
hamburg zwei junge männer haben sich
mamas auto dafür geschnappt und diesmal
diesmal gab es verletzte
mittwochnacht in hamburg ein bmw m 240 1
340 ps bolide der superklasse komplett
demoliert am steuer zwei junge männer
die sich den 60.000 euro teuren
schlitten schnell mal von mutti
ausgeliehen haben einmal richtig putzen
und mit mamas bmw ordentlich gas geben
im wahrsten sinne eine lebensgefährliche
schnapsidee denn die beiden hatten vor
ihrer spritztour ordentlich getankt den
alkoholtest hat der fahrer mehr als
bestanden 1,8 und 70 grummelt und damit
der alkoholpegel stabil bleibt haben
sich die jungen männer vor ihrem
waghalsigen ausflug auch noch ein fabia
eingeladen das motto des fahrers bmw
oder ballermann in jedem fall
badelatschen mit
ordentlich karacho ging es dann durch
die hamburger innenstadt am ende eines
autotunnels verlor sohnemann die
kontrolle über das auto der wagen
knallte mehrfach gegen die tunnelwand
und überschlug sich totalschaden und die
beiden jungs waren nicht alleine worauf
stehen trotz proleten richtig möpse
gleich zwei davon sassen auf der
rückbank während die beiden raser wie
durch ein wunder unversehrt geblieben
sind trug einer der möpse jedoch schwere
verletzungen davon er würde direkt am
unfallort von der feuerwehr versorgt
nachuntersuchungen umgehend in eine
tierklinik gebracht erst der
ermittlungen der polizei haben ergeben
dass der sucht fahrer mit viel zu hoher
geschwindigkeit unterwegs gewesen ist
laut der polizei hamburg kann man von
einem illegalen autorennen ausgehen
sowohl die mutter als auch die trunken
fahrer selbst wollen sich nicht zu
äußern
was von dieser gemeingefährlichen
raserei übrig bleibt sind ein auto mit
totalschaden
zwei betrunkene junge männer mit einem
führerschein weniger zwei traumatisierte
möpse und mehrere flaschen bier immerhin
noch ungeöffnet new york versinkt in der
gewalt das berichten unsere reporter von
dort seit monaten jeden tag neue brutale
gewalttaten in der stadt schauen sie mal
nur auf diese polizei
nachrichtenmeldungen der letzten stunden
in der branche haben randalierer
glasflaschen auf diese polizisten
geworfen die polizisten werden brutal
attackiert sehen sie was da auf der
straße los war als die polizisten einen
mann wegen unerlaubten waffenbesitzes
dort festnehmen wollten gewalt gegen die
dann die in new york für ordnung sorgen
wollen und auch das ist wenig später
passiert in queens im östlichen teil new
yorks es ist da ein teenie der vor dem
wohnhaus erschossen worden ist er 14
jahre alt erst in einer garagenzufahrt
getötet und zudem polizeimeldungen der
letzten stunden gehört auch das aus
manhattan im schicken soho ein martial
arts kämpfer der hatte einen obdachlosen
zu boden gerissen der zuvor von
passanten brutal attackiert der zuvor
passanten brutal attackiert hatte ja das
ist die alltägliche gewalt in new york
und nur ein kleiner einblick in das was
in dieser metropole so in den letzten
stunden bei der polizei gemeldet wurde
wir sprechen mit unserem new york
korrespondent herbert bauernebel grüße
dich herzlich herbert warum das
berichtet du ja seit monaten
mittlerweile immer mehr brutale gewalt
in deiner stadt
es gibt verschiedene faktoren die
einfach hier latent für diese
gewaltwelle sorgen die eine gewaltwelle
die einfach nicht abebben mag es ist
einerseits natürlich den nachwirkungen
der korona virus pandemie hier in new
york und natürlich auch der den unruhen
es gab nach dem tod von george floyd all
das hat zu einem dramatischen anstieg
bei der gewalt geführt besonders auch
bei schuss vorfällen in diesem bereich
ist es in den letzten wochen ein wenig
nach unten gegangen es gab mehr
verhaftungen von menschen mit waffen das
ist ein erster kleiner erfolg aber
insgesamt ist nach wie vor die
verbrechensrate um 31% höher als selbst
im gewalttätigen vorjahr um das ist
natürlich ein wirkliches
schreckenszenario besonders in einem
kritischen moment führen new york city
denn die stadt ist nach wie gesagt zwei
jahren pandemie um george wright unruhen
bietet den ersten sommer halbwegs normal
und leidet eben nach wie vor unter
dieser hohen kriminalität die nach wie
vor menschen abschreckt zurückzukommen
ins büro hier in new york und auch
einige touristen natürlich abschnitte
welche rolle spielen drogen
die drogenkriminalität ist relativ
stabil geblieben dass eines der größten
probleme scheint zu sein da ist der
liberale strafvollzug hier in new york
wird reformen gegeben die bedeuten dass
menschen wenn sie behauptet werden
eigentlich garantiert eine kaution
hinterlegen können sie werden dem
richter vorgeführt und dann wie beim
dreitürer eigentlich können sie wieder
hinaus und viele beginnen weitere
straftaten es ist jetzt gerade ein mann
hier berühmt geworden in new york mit
101 belastungen wegen ladendiebstahl
hauptsächlich jedes mal wieder
freigelassen worden jedes mal wieder ein
verbrechen begangen und das frustriert
natürlich den neuen bürgermeister eric
adams der hier aufräumen möchte aber
auch natürlich die polizeit die hier
immer wieder gegen teilweise die
gleichen leute vorgehen muss new york
hat es ist deine stadt seit so vielen
jahren gibt es gegenden die für dich
absolut no go ist also wo auch herbert
bauernebel unser us korrespondent sagt
nee da kann ich da will ich auf keinen
fall hingehen regierung in new york
man muss es nicht so ganz dramatisch
sehen aber es gibt gegenden die man
gerne meinen möchte natürlich was hier
ein im all begonnen unheimlich geworden
ist ist die zufälligkeit dieser
gewalttaten und es kann einem hier in
new york wirklich überall treffen in der
u-bahn am gehsteig es sind sehr viele
menschen hier unterwegs die
offensichtlich geistige erkrankungen
haben die unberechenbar sind sehr viele
obdachlose
es ist schon ein bisschen ein gefühl wo
man sich über die schulter schauen dass
dieses gefühl hatte ich eigentlich vor
zwei drei vier jahren hier nicht in new
york sagt herbert bauernebel unser new
york korrespondent danke für deine
einschätzung new york eine stadt die
immer mehr in der kriminalität versinkt
wir schauen jetzt auf dem
bundesgesundheitsminister karl
lauterbach er hat corona erst ist er
gerade frisch geimpft das hat er ja
mitgeteilt karl lauterbach zum vierten
mal und jetzt hat er sich angesteckt am
abend erstmals positiv getestet sein
ministerium hat das vor wenigen stunden
bestätigt in der erklärung können wir
kurz reinschauen pressemitteilung heißt
es der minister habe leichte symptome
nur würde jetzt von zu hause weiter
arbeiten und weiter heißt es da er habe
sich trotz dieser vierten impfung
infiziert und das ministerium ruft dann
auch in dem letzten satz hier in der
pressemitteilung wider zu dieser vierten
impfung auf und das ist schon
interessant denn für lauterbach konnte
diese infektion in wahrheit zur
politischen unzeit denn gerade erst hat
er ja mit seinen regierungskollegen
ministerkollegen vor allen dingen mit
justizminister marco buschmann gemeinsam
den plan der ampel regierung für den
corona herbst und winter bekanntgegeben
vorgestellt und da wird schon ja ein
massiver impf druck wieder ausgeübt
selbst auf dreifach geimpfte und die
vierfach impfung als lösung gepriesen
und jetzt eben natürlich auch wieder
eine infektion trotz fürther impfung in
jedem fall aber wünschen wir von bild
hier gute besserung an den minister an
herrn lauterbach und wir blicken auf den
fall der uns auf fühlt wie kein zweiter
der fall weil ihn die woche hat damit
begonnen mit der nachricht dass der
mutmaßliche mörder von eileen
polizeibekannt ist mehr noch dass ihr
mutmaßliche mörder ein verurteilter
sexualstraftäter ist einer dem man
wieder raus gelassen hat aus der
psychiatrie nach zehn jahren am ende
dieser woche nach langen recherchen
unserer reporter ist klar dieser fall
aline der ist auch das dramatische
versagen der behörden
eileen 14 jahre jung brutal ermordet sie
könnte noch leben wenn polizei und
justiz konsequent gehandelt hätten immer
mehr unglaubliche details kommen jetzt
ans licht immer wieder fiel alliance
mörder dadurch auf dass er sich an
kinder und junge mädchen heran machte
niemand stoppte ihn bis es zu spät war
jan heiko stock vor dem mord an eileen
ein weiteres opfer eine 17 jährige das
mädchen und die schule alarmieren die
polizei doch nichts geschieht und die
schande geht weiter jan heiko p der mann
der zehn jahre wegen versuchter
vergewaltigung einer elfjährigen im
maßregelvollzug saß legt beschwerde
wegen seiner dauerhaften überwachung ein
und unfassbar das landgericht limburg
gibt ihm recht wie kann das sein bild
fragt den richter und autor thorsten
schleif war das beenden der
führungsaufsicht wirklich juristisch
notwendig warum soll bei einem
verurteilten
sexualstraftäter der versucht hat ein
kind zu vergewaltigen und erneut
straffällig geworden ist eine
unbefristete führungsaufsicht
unverhältnismäßig sein das ist unfug am
25 januar endet die frist zur
überwachung damit laufen alle maßnahmen
wie die führungsaufsicht aus bei einer
solchen tat sollte die unbefristete
führungsaufsicht bereits bei der ersten
verurteilung angeordnet werden hier ist
eine gesetzesänderung dringend
erforderlich ist darf doch nicht sein
dass ein pädophiler sexualstraftäter
irgendwann aus der überwachung fällt und
was tut die polizei sie führt beim
späteren mörder nur eine einzige
gefährde ansprache durch eindeutig zu
wenig meint richter torsten schlaf es
wäre auch zulässig gewesen mehrere
gefährderansprachen durchzuführen um zu
zeigen wir haben dich im blick ich kenne
auch polizeibeamte die das gemacht das
verheerende fazit wenn gericht
staatsanwaltschaft und polizei ihre
möglichkeiten besser ausgeschöpft und
gehandelt hätten dann könnte er ihn
heute noch leben
jetzt können wir jetzt in der geschichte
die ist wirklich unglaublich man muss so
so so viel pech haben und dann kriegst
du einen junge auch wirklich noch einen
schock ein junge der diesen traktor
gefahren hat in weilerswist in nordrhein
westfalen ein 16-jähriger und der hart
bei der hitze auf dem feld geholfen hat
den traktor oder stundenlang über das
feld gefahren und dann das dann hat er
sich weit und bereits leider einen
einzigen strommast ausgesucht der dort
eine 110000 volt stromleitung durchführt
dieser mast umgeknickt aber das ist
eigentlich eine riesige folgen für
zehntausende stromkunden 65.000 menschen
vier stunden lang und teilweise länger
ohne strom was wenn die geschichte team
steckt unser bild reporter ist genau
dort in weilerswist vor dem wie man
unschwer erkennen kann immer noch
geknickten strommast dort und mich
interessiert vor allen dingen dieser
16-jährige dieses traktor kind dieser
traktor teenie wie konnte das passieren
ehrlicherweise ich leider ein bisschen
geht
ja irgendwie alles so ein bisschen
draußen unterwegs mal gefragt wie steht
ihr zu der ganzen sache natürlich auch
alle anwohner ja ist ein gutes omen ist
einfach großes pech ihr könnt euch mal
dieses riesige feld hier zeigen ob es
wirklich ein unglaublich weites feld und
ihr
stroh hat und in genau diesen spruch ist
der arme junge reingefahren er hat das
gestern gegenüber diesen anderen mit dem
wir eben sprechen kommen so begründet
angeblich seien die linke blockiert
gewesen und darüber hinaus auch die
bremse das team wollte eigentlich
relativ nah an gewohnt fahren eben daran
entlang gehen kurz vor hat aber bedenken
blockiert und dann konnte er nicht nur
ausweichend ist in diesem masse abheben
wie ihr seht komplett
und dann kam auch das recht zu diesem
stoff der strom dagegen natürlich der
leitung und der arme junge hat sie dann
angesagt auch noch angst selber
irgendwie
stromschlag er ist dann trotzdem draußen
spruch es ist alles gut gegangen gegeben
so weit offen und mit seinen das ganze
das ist auch ganz interessant auch wenn
es auf dem feld passiert ist übrigens
und ganz normalen verkehrsunfall er wird
also jetzt antreten kommt und sich dann
äußern also egal ob man bleiben schon
drauf werden oder eben einen strommast
oben das scheint die polizei erstmal
eins zumindest hier klar der strommast
ist nicht schuld also damals in dem fall
leider nicht schieben teams wechseln der
bild-reporter danke dir
und wir bleiben im wald und da lässt
sich jemand blickenden kenne schon da
allzu gut und der macht auch mal
probleme hier sehen sie sozusagen
sollten hinterteil in die kamera ja das
ist eine wild hier falle die hat diesen
beweis jetzt geliefert der problembär in
bayern des zurück er ist wieder da der
bär zurück in bayern diesmal in bad tölz
wieder streift ein bär durch die
bayerischen wälder verbreitet angst und
schrecken bei mensch und tier am
wochenende tappt der braunbär durch
diese fotofalle gibt sich zu erkennen
schon im mai bären alarm pünktlich zum
g7-gipfel dem treffen der mächtigsten
regierungschefs der welt schleicht ein
bär durch die wälder l maus kommt den
mächtigsten männern der welt ganz nah
und lässt bauern verzweifeln
schafzüchter christian euler entsetzt
ist es ungewöhnlich dass ein bär so
viele so viele in seiner art und weise
tötet
erschrocken entsetzt zu wollen dass wir
die bilder gesehen haben also einen
tierfreund und wenn du das herz weh wenn
man sowas ist der g7 bär nun zurück
handelt es sich gar um einen weiteren
bären noch ungewiss erst wenn code oder
haare des tieres gefunden werden können
diese brisanz fragen geklärt werden
allerdings die erneute bären sichtung
weckt erinnerungen an 2006 als ganz
deutschland über den problembären von
bayern diskutiert
dann haben wir normal verhalten er lebt
im wald gibt niemals raus
und reißt vielleicht ein bis zwei schafe
ja
wir haben dann einen unterschied
zwischen dem normalen sich halt wer die
hardware und dem problembär da gibt es
nur die lösung ihn zu beseitigen weil
einfach die phase groß ist und jetzt der
braunbär von bad tölz endet es ähnlich
dramatisch wie 2006 als problembär bruno
abgeschossen wird oder kommt das tier
mit heiler haut davon und verschwindet
schnell wieder von der bildfläche
darüber sprechen wir mit unserem bild
reporter jörg völkerling jetzt der schon
vor dem g7 gipfel ja quasi auf der jagd
war auf der suche war nach diesem
problembären jetzt kann man hier im
studio sitzen und sagen frau ist ja eine
lustige geschichte aber das ist schon
ein problem für die menschen dort in bad
tölz im moment
ja in der tat die sehen das ganze gar
nicht locker und die sehen das auch
nicht so wie der bund naturschutz der
meint man müsse den bären willkommen
heißen in bayern für die almbauern ist
das ein fast existenzielles problem wir
waren ja ende mai mit dem bergbau und
christian noyer unterwegs der auch schon
2006 betroffen war von problembär bruno
und der uns einfach erzählte dass dieser
bär vor elektrozäunen ich halt macht vor
schluchten die auch hochklettert nicht
halt macht also alle schutzkonzepte
funktionieren nicht und was das brisante
ist es gab jetzt auch offenbar die erste
begegnung von einem menschen mit diesem
wären eine frau bei mittenwald am lauter
see also exakt diesen see diesem
campingplatz dem wir gerade in dem
beitrag gesehen haben ist dem br jetzt
zum ersten mal mit ihrem hund begegnet
sie hatten augenkontakt sichtkontakt sie
war wie paralysiert hat sie gesagt
konnte sich nicht bewegen der bär hat
sich dann von selber durchs unterholz
davon geschlichen und es wird also
wirklich ihm von tag zu tag brennender
dass die leute sich auch vertraut machen
mit den verhaltensregeln die das
landesamt für umwelt in bayern als wenn
man einen bären sie sang leise reden auf
sich aufmerksam machen ganz vorsichtig
die arme bewegen wenn es zu einem
angriff kommen sollte dann auf den boden
legen die hände in den nacken
möglicherweise ein rucksack der schutz
bietet ein bär würde sich in gruppen im
normalfall im prinzip nur nähern und
schnuppern und dann von einem ablassen
aber naja der normalfall bei einem bären
der schon so die scheu verloren hat ein
menschliches gebiet vorzudringen ich
weiß nicht ob das so wirklich ein trost
ist für die leute wo soll der denn
eigentlich wieder hin zurück dieser wer
also jetzt hat man so ein paar tipps und
hofft natürlich dass sie jetzt nicht
noch mehr kommen das sind ja eher
einzelgänger diese tiere aber wohin will
man denn mit ihm wohl allein
na ja die frage ist weniger wo man ihn
gerne hätte sondern wo es den iren hin
treibt sind offenbar männliche tiere und
ist offenbar auch nicht nur 1 1 100er
der in diesem grenzbereich karwendel
wetterstein jetzt bad tölz unterwegs ist
während die auf der partnersuche sind
nach weiblichen bären und die offenbar
aus einer bärenpopulation im trentino
stammen dort gibt es 60 bären tendenz
steigend die alle auch offenbar so
schimpfen auch die ein bauern in bayern
mit schaafs kadavern gefüttert worden
sind und damit erst quasi so richtig
scharf gemacht worden sind auf die beute
und es gab im juli eine sichtung
ausgerechnet auf dem postweg bären bad
in tirol und es gab diese diesen riss
ende mai bei scharnitz auf der bär alte
also man hat fast das gefühl der bär ist
da auf historischen wanderpfaden
unterwegs die auch entsprechend deswegen
nach insel benannt sind also einhalt
gebieten kann man ihm nicht man kann es
vielleicht mit markus söder halten der
am dienstag ist auf eine almwanderung
mit seiner landschafts
landwirtschaftsministerin unterwegs
waren zum thema wolf gesagt hat der
gehört hier nicht hin und auch darauf
vorbereitet hat dass man hier über
entnahme nachdenken muss und auch
möglicherweise die voraussetzung
schaffen muss bären die sich
menschlicher behausungen besiedlung
annähern auch schießen können muss danke
für deine information der problembär in
bayern ist zurück in und um bad tölz
jörg völkerling unser bild reporter
danke dir
[Musik]